وابدا معك اسماعيل الغول وهذه الاستهدافات
الكثيفه في مدينه غزه على قطاعات
مختلفه نعم بالتحديد في القاطع الجنوبي
الغربي لمدينه غزه من شارع عشره ومنطقه تل
الهواء ومنطقه الشيخ عجلين نتحدث عن قصف
مدفعي عنيف ومتواصل في هذه المنطقه
بالاضافه الى القاء عشرات القنابل
الدخانيه على منطقه حي الرمال ومنطقه شارع
الوحده ومحيط منطقه الصرايه هذه المناطق
التي تشهد تواجدا كثيفا لقوه الاحتلال
وانتشار للقناصه الاسرائيليه التي تصل
مديات رصاصاته الى كيلو او 2 ك م من اماكن
تواجد قوات الاحتلال وتتعمد قوات الاحتلال
بايقاع هذه الرصاصات في مقتل لكن حتى هذه
اللحظه بعد الثلاث ايام الماضيه التي وصل
عدد كبير من الشهداء بالاضافه لعدد كبير
من الاصابات الى مستشفى المعمداني برصاص
القناصه حتى هذه اللحظه لم يصل هذا اليوم
اي من الاصابات يبدو ان المواطنين اتخذوا
حذرهم بشكل ملحوظ جدا في التوجه لهذه
المناطق لكن على الصعيد الاخر نتحدث عن
الجانب الانساني منذ امس وصل وصل الى
مستشفى المعمداني ثلاثه اطفال ماتوا بردا
وجوعا في منطقه شمال غزه بالتحديد وايضا
خوفا تحدث الاطباء والمصادر الطبيه ان
التوقف القلب بشكل مفاجئ لدى هؤلاء
الاطفال بسبب الخوف الشديد والقصف المستمر
على هذه المناطق وهذه تضع قوات الاحتلال
ايضا امام جرائم جديده بحق الاطفال القصف
المتواصل على الاطفال وبالاضافه الى موت
الاطفال بالخوف والجوع والبرد المستمر على
شمال قطاع غزه في ظل عدم تواجد اغطيه
كافيه وفي ظل عدم دخول ايضا المساعدات
الانسانيه الى شمال قطاع غزه يكون الضحايا
من الاطفال والنساء وفق ما تحدثت وزاره
الصحه من قبل ان 70% من الضحايا هم اطفال
ونساء بالقصف الاسرائيلي واليوم يقع ضحايا
الاحتلال ايضا من البرد والجوع هم الاطفال
والنساء الذين يستمر مرحله نزوحهم مره
ومرتين وثلاث في ظل ايضا صمودهم وصبرهم
على كل ما تتعرض له هذه العائلات من قوات
الاحتلال ورفضهم على مخطط التهجير ورفضهم
ايضا بالتوجه الى المناطق الجنوبيه التي
تحدث عنها فيما قبل الاحتلال انها امنه
لكن فيما بعد استمرت عمليه العسكريه في
المناطق الجنوبيه واوقع عشرات الفلسطينيين
من الضحايا والشهداء ايضا على المستوى
الصحي نتحدث عن كارثه صحيه كبيره في ظل
محاصره قوات الاحتلال المناطق الغربيه
الجنوبيه لمستشفى الشفاء ومنع وصعوبه وصول
اي من الطواقم الطبيه الى ذاك المكان بسبب
المخاطر الكبيره من القناصه الاسرائيليه
بالاضافه الى القصف المستمر واطلاق
القنابل الدخانيه على محيط المجمع نتحدث
عن تكدس عدد كبير من الاصابات داخل مستشفى
المعمداني وانتظار عدد كبير ايضا على جدول
العمليات وهم بحاجه عاجله الى تدخل طبي
دون توفر الكادر الطبي الكافي ودون توفر
ايضا الطواقم اللوازم الطبيه الكافيه في
المناطق الشماليه لقطاع غزه